all right get this we're only 15 minutes
away 15 months away not minutes from the
2024 presidential election Democrats
they are desperately trying to force
Americans to focus on anything and
everything other than their parties
presumptive nominee that would be your
old Grandpa Uncle Joe Biden now that
includes the Democrats in Biden's
Department of Justice and other
Democratic prosecutors all around the
country all making headlines with the
Bevy of suspiciously timed indictments
against what is right now Joe Biden's
Chief political rival that would be
Donald J Trump Biden himself he's
nowhere to be found as the 2024 campaign
ramps up all the president of the United
States who is supposedly running for
reelection is spending his next 10 days
at the beach by the way when he has no
shirt on it is not a pretty sight
he is not in the White House
demonstrating quote leadership he's not
on the campaign Trail winning over
voters by the way there's a picture of
Joe being held up by his wife Jill
walking along the beach seemingly to
struggle uh in Delaware in the night's
sand he is by the way uh during the day
demonstrating his ability to leisurely
ride a bicycle he didn't fall today good
job Joe we're proud of you
out of sight out of mind or at least
that's what Democrats in the media mob
would like you to think they want you to
focus only on Trump indictments core
proceedings January 6 documents anything
other than Joe Biden and we went through
the timeline last night if Joe Biden
gets bad news the next day there's
another Trump indictment shocking but
despite all the hysteria and cooked up
political charges and indictments
against Donald Trump the weak case about
what payments in New York from eight
years ago documents at Mar-A-Lago by the
way didn't Hillary Clinton have top
secret classified documents uh if I
remember no reasonable prosecutor
whatever prosecute didn't she delete 33
000 subpoenaed emails with bleach bit no
rate at the Chappaqua home no arrest to
Hillary Clinton no charges brought in
that case and by the way the same thing
with Joe Biden he had documents and not
in one place in four separate places not
one of them rated uh and no charges
against him either in fact the only
candidate by the way that if we talk
about Accused by a credible FBI source
of taking money from a foreign National
in exchange for a policy decision that
is the one guy struggling to walk on
that Beach in Delaware
and struggling to even meet move a beach
chair in Delaware and that is the
sitting president of the United States
of America in other words Joe Biden's
serious very real bribery allegations
now in addition to Biden's deteriorating
mental and physical abilities these
corruption allegations against the
president this is a clear criminal
danger the media can ignore it all they
want but this is real we all know that
Biden lied about his involvement in his
son's Shady international business deals
he said over and over and over again I
never once talked to my son Hunter my
brother
or my brother or anybody for that matter
about their foreign business deals no he
didn't just talk to them he was involved
in them we know about the paper trail of
shell corporations we know about the
suspicious activity reports and we know
about foreign cash often from our top
geopolitical foes flowing magically into
the Biden family coffers and a business
led by a person that admitted at the
time he was a crack addict with no
experience at all in the businesses that
they were engaging in with some of our
our strongest enemies now we know about
the mountain of Hard Evidence on
Hunter's hard drive implicating his very
own father linking him directly to
financial payments from these foreign
business deals you know half my income
goes to Pops 10 percent for the big guy
oh I'm sick and tired of paying for
pops's home repairs we also know about
the IRS whistleblowers and the witnesses
claiming to have recordings we know all
of this looks very bad for Joe Biden
although you wouldn't know if if you
were watching any other channel but fox
now of course thanks to Biden's Ultra
partisan and weaponized doj Joe Biden
will not be seriously investigated or
held accountable but he will be tried in
the court of public opinion and all of
the this before 2024 that probably is
all in the end that will likely matter
and right now Biden's poll numbers
they're frankly abysmal look at the New
York Times Siena poll the president's
approval rating at a low 39 percent and
a head-to-head matchup well there's a
new poll out tonight by Insider
Advantage Donald Trump up by one in this
poll uh they are now tied at 43 percent
each a growing number of Voters are now
doubting Biden's character they no
longer trust him they don't think he is
physically mentally cognitively up to
the job and frankly they don't even like
him as a person because over the last
few years we have now witnessed the real
Joe Biden up close and personal and
frankly it's not a very pretty picture
by the way it's not just these very real
bribery allegations and his cognitive
troubles you know and his odd mood
swings and frankly
um we saw this in Finland pretty creepy
Behavior by Joe Biden that's been seen
over and over again don't let your
children near the guy
many Americans were repulsed by Joe and
Dr Jill Biden's attitude towards their
own seventh grandchild four-year-old
beautiful little girl in Arkansas who
until recently was totally shunned by
the entire Biden family that's a pretty
mean soulless despicable thing to do the
child's mother wanted her daughter to be
part of the Biden family but they
rejected this four-year-old girl over
and over and over again wouldn't even
acknowledge her existence that was of
course until last Friday when terrible
poll numbers forced Biden to finally
have to acknowledge that his own
granddaughter is alive and living in
Arkansas in what was a weekend news dump
and he now says he wants to meet her for
the very first time in four years what a
loving Grandpa Joe is now if you want to
know who Joe Biden really is as a person
you can look no further than this story
he is not the the sweet loving congenial
grandpa that he would like you to
believe he is frankly what we're
witnessing and learning is we're seeing
a cold calculating career politician who
cares more about wealth and Status than
his own family and by the way when you
see Joe Biden through that lens all the
corruption all the bribery allegations
seem very plausible don't they hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else